hector garza right now the national
border patrol council vice president um
hector i mean these are staggering
numbers uh but i must give credit to you
you were looking at these before anyone
was and that it could get that high if
not if not higher um i'm just wondering
if were there any signs that the
mexicans are doing anything to either
slow this down or halt it out right
so first of all the fact that we're
having the largest caravan ever should
be of no surprise to anyone uh we know
that for the past uh a few months of the
past few years the bible board policies
have been having open borders and this
is a result of those policies uh the
other thing is that we know that mexico
is not being a good neighbor they're not
doing their part in securing the
southern border and they're not doing
their part in to create their northern
border uh which is our southern border
with with mexico uh we need to make sure
that the biden uh forces mexico to do
their part if not we're gonna continue
to get overwhelmed uh just a couple days
ago here in laredo texas we had two uh
aliens that were dead uh found dead in
the back of a tractor trader there was
more than one hundred illegal aides
stopped in the back of that tractor
trailer then just yesterday we had
another alien that uh found stuff in a
in a in a tractor uh here in in some
branch last year laredo so this board
situation is out of control human
suffering and human misery will continue
as long as these open board policies
continue with joe biden and you want to
reach out to mexico to see what they can
do but we're learning hector that
mexico's president will not be attending
this summit of the americas so the
chance that that that the president and
the mexican president can iron out these
issues that that doesn't appear to be
you know
in the cards right now
well you know uh president obama needs
to uh pressure uh a president or mexican
president
and make sure that they do their part uh
we we know that uh having open borders
is not humane uh people uh migrants are
dying on the border uh and it's not
humane and we need to make sure that
that our president does his job now uh
where's kamala harris uh she's supposed
to be the borders are and she hasn't
come to the border and she hasn't done
any of it any of the work that she's
supposed to be doing so uh unfortunately
the the deaths on the border will
continue
hector i hope you're wrong but you've
been uncannily prescient on this hector
uh thank you very much secretary of the
national border patrol council hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now